i want to talk about the triangulation
um so there's obviously now we're
talking about math we're talking about
science we're talking about
ancient spirituality we're talking about
consciousness
uh we're talking about all of these uh
sacred
sorts of um especially
the last thousands of years this is from
axial ages of explosion through
uh scientific renaissance and explosion
there in scientific method and whatnot
coming together and triangulating on
what this nature of reality is and
that i think it's interesting as we were
talking about the source code mountain
and all these different
ways up in exploration we
we kind of we we we may have
mentioned this slightly um that
could it be that the
uh that the ancient perennial spiritual
wisdom
of everything being one
integration everything being one thing
and then also
having the small derivations like a
calculus of consciousness they're small
derivatives of us nerve endings
uh having the conscious agent
experiences and interactions
and that cause actions to change and
whatnot
that that the triangulation of
that and on um
the science that is being pushed uh from
like your conversation theory and many
others are just pointing at this
the same thing over thousands of years
or we're coming to the same thing and
that kind of
maybe indicates that there is that one
monte top with many different paths
i want to i want to see um what you
think about
the the candy store analogy is very
strong it's it's very strong the the
candy store um analogy for the conscious
agent experience and my question would
be
would be this i've i've been
i've been struggling with trying to to
understand
this that for thousands of years there
have been
ancient spiritualities that have talked
about how
everything that is possible
already is that's what infinity is
infinity is
everything that is possible it's all the
combinatorics that are possible
are already happening and and the
being becoming is the only being
so it's just an infinite amount of
becoming always eternally happening
and that all the combinatories that
exist do but then there's kurt girdle
and there's this incompleteness theorem
and
there's this idea that it's it's
impossible to ever
be everything it's impossible to ever be
all the combinatorics possible
so are we are we are we already
exploring all of the combinatorics of
the infinite candy store
always and always will or
can we never explore all of the combat
torques of the
infinite candy store and therefore um
and and and maybe um the oroboros
could i can bring that in as well just
that that
as we evolve to whatever the godhead
attractor
is that we're going towards maybe the
recursive function
is to just continue tasting more of the
candy store combinatorics as conscious
agents and that's
that transcension hypothesis at the
godhead that we just go
inward for more exploring so take us on
that journey of those two options and
then on we'll get to that recursive god
head
right so girdle
when he was only i think two years old
or 25 years old
25 yep crazy in 1931
he he did one of the most brilliant
things
ever in human history he
proved his incompleteness theorems and
and
effectively what he showed was
that if you have any set of like axioms
assumptions for a mathematical system
that's rich enough
to do arithmetic then he showed that
there will always be
statements that are true mathematical
statements that are true
but you cannot prove from your axioms
so these are unprovable truths they're
trues that are unprovable
now you can imagine the genius that it
would take to prove that there are
unprovable truths what he did
and now if you take those truths that
are unprovable and add them to your
axioms
you might think oh well then i'm done
but then he proved
no there will be yet new
truths that are unprovable within the
richer and so
what this means is that there is no
end to exploration of mathematical
structure
it's and it it seems
to be an unending
exploration that that even an infinite
wisdom
could never get around right that
there's a sense in which
you can't ever be smart enough to
comprehend the whole thing this is this
is pretty deep this is
an exploration that in principle appears
to never ever be possible to stop
in prison like the infinite um men
benoit
mandelbrot fractal zoom that's right
but this is the kind i mean there if you
take the um
the real line from zero to one there's
points but yeah you can see them all
right
there's some sense in which it's
comprehensible this is
different this is like yeah it's it's
unending and
so now how it relates to the the
consciousness stuff and what you're
talking about is
um if now i'm again bracketing with
respect to a particular theory right so
suppose we adopt the theory in which
consciousness
conscious experiences are fundamental
right so
then in under that idea
mathematical structure is only about one
thing consciousness and conscious
experiences
and in that framework then you would
girdle would be telling us that there's
an infinite variety
of conscious experiences with an
infinite variety of different structures
and that may be a little strange to a
lot of people to talk about experiences
being structured
right but if you if you think about just
your experience of the
of the world around you there's up down
left right forward and backward there's
there's a structure a three-dimensional
structure to your to your space and
and there's a structure of color space
it turns out that for example
red is a little bit closer to orange
than it is to blue
right there's this there's there's a
closeness relationship that colors have
in our our perceptions and everywhere
there's a field called psychophysics
that's been around since 1860 a guy
named gustav fechner started it
but in that field what we do is we study
conscious experiences
and their structure and their structure
all over the place so
all conscious experiences they're more
than mathematics
so no consciousness experience is just
mathematics
but each conscious experience is
structured
so i like to think of it is that the
conscious experience is to the
mathematical structure
like the living organism is to its bones
so it's like
mathematics is the bones of
consciousness consciousness is not just
his bones it's
it's much richer than that but it's not
less than his bones
it it it has to have the bones as well
so
so what girdle is telling us under this
theory that consciousness is all there
is that's this fundamental
is that there's this infinite variety of
conscious experiences with an infinite
variety of
structures so that's what i call
girdle's candy story because these are
now
things to be experienced like candies
right you know the kid in the candy
store was like let me try this one oh
that was great now let's try this new
experience now i love chocolate well
i like caramel too and not even so what
girdle is
inviting us in this in this framework is
to say that
there's this infinite range of conscious
experiences and
no consciousness of any type
even the most glorified can ever come to
the end of the exploration
and so there will be this endless
exploration
of all the possible forms of conscience
that we could actually think of
gurdwar's theorem
as telling us that that what it's about
is consciousness
learning more and more about itself as
it explores more and more of its
possibilities
but it will never end and um and we're
all
perhaps are
quote-unquote we are that we are that
yeah the um we are that or
i and my father are one yeah that that's
right and we're exploring it in a
particular minkowski space format
with objects in space and time and this
is the particular little
so but that's what that fits in with
this headset idea like so instead of
taking space and time
as the final reality in this bigger
girl's candy store picture it's right no
this headset that we've assumed was the
final reality
is one candy in an unbounding candy
store
it's just one and what
so part of the waking up is to recognize
this rookie mistake
that we took this chocolate as the only
candy in the store this is the whole
thing it's all about chocolate well now
it's not all about space and time
and what's inside space and time that's
just one little headset one candy in the
candy store
wake up to all the infinite
possibilities again
you mentioned you mentioned this earlier
something like a walt disney or a pixar
style imagination
where if you do imagine what it is like
to
uh evolve a headset that is non-carbon
based dna
coded beings in a space-time quantum
field theory
soup of natural selection that then
maybe
you can you can envision what other
simulated uh
designs of realities look like uh and
you could even wander just
a couple solar systems over and think
about what it would be like
um you could even stay in this universe
if you want and you could
explore what what uh alternative
so so does it does it feel like that
then we
are already
all of the infinite candy store
combinatorics always happening or that
we can never be that
and we are always endlessly exploring
that well
girdle seems to be saying we're
endlessly exploring and and
that that you're right that we can
certainly try to imagine
and explore outside of the standard
space-time kinds of things
um but there are certain interesting
limits
to this too that we have right now so
for example if i
this is one of my favorite examples of
this if i ask you to imagine
a specific color that you've never seen
before
oh yeah but does anything happen
suppose you're color blind right so
you're you're a guy you're red green
color blind
and and so there's this whole range of
color experiences that you can't have
that you know every almost every woman
has and
and color normal men have so there's
this red green distinction that you
don't have
but if i asked a color blind man to
imagine red
well he can't do it right just like you
can't imagine a new color
i can't imagine a new color so if so
there are some
really if i can't even imagine one
simple color i i know colors right i've
had lots of color experiences
but all my imagination does not allow me
to imagine
outside the color wheel right yeah
really well i can't i can't do it
and and yet we know that there are
creatures
um for example there are some women who
have four color receptors
not just three so most of us know a long
medium and short wavelength cone
but these women have apparently two
versions of the long wavelength cone
and they in some women there all four of
them are expressed in the retina
and when you do careful tests on these
women so kimberly jameson
of um a phd researcher here at uc irvine
who i know has she and others have done
careful tests
these women give clear evidence that
they're
that that can be interpreted that
they're in a richer color world than the
rest of us
just like us trichromats we are in a
richer world
than the colorblind men these women are
in a richer color world than us
so they're having color experiences
that i can't even imagine i can't
imagine what they
i can imagine abstractly that they're
having them but i can't imagine
concretely any one of those experiences
and so that's the limit that we're going
to have right now
it appears yeah our understanding of the
possibilities and some says
we can understand abstractly
the possibility of all these realms of
all the candies in the candy store yeah
but until you taste the candy
like yeah four percent of people are
synesthetes and
um there's creatures that see an
infrared and on the other side on the
ultraviolet like there's a different
species umvelts so
the different um yeah so species are
wearing different
headsets and we could you know we can we
took the uh
channel uh rhodopsin for optogenetics
and we took
um the the uh
the green fluorescent protein gfp for
the
um for other biotech work that we've
been using so
we've we we're borrowing from headsets
uh from
like user interfaces to yeah so
um this is very good if you can't
imagine outside of the color
wheel um of our user interface
then it's hard to like walt disney or
pixar yourself
out of uh into like different universe
designs
as well but um i think virtual reality
does a really good job
at trying to slowly in a sense kind of
like
stretch out your color wheel beyond um
because when you're when you go in and
these things are just getting more and
more indistinguishable
so that inevitably it's going to lead to
a point where um where you may be
um spending um your
your your 80 years engrossed in the game
because we've also hit the longevity
escape velocity so you can now live
because we're just home we're just we're
just we're just engineering
out any of the disease we're just tuning
the car
or the plane um we give uh to like 15
year old homeostatic capacity of our
body over and over again
so you can play for those 80 years and
then and then take it out and then just
be like wow that was vanilla that was
great and now it's like
back to uh carmel for now and then uh
yeah
yeah yeah so yeah i think vr will help i
agree it'll help
stretch our imaginations it'll help to
take us in different places
and i think it will also help um
to understand the possibility that
what we assumed was the objective
reality space we would assume the space
and time and physical objects the sun
and the moon and stars
these are the absolute ground of reality
and but someone who's actually you know
the next generation that sort of grows
up and spends a lot of time in
virtual realities that are just as
immersive and compelling as everyday
life
it's it's got it's not going to be you
won't have to be really a genius to take
off your headset
and just wonder well what about this
this is this is just another headset
i mean you don't have you won't have to
be an einstein to do that it'll just
sort of be like duh
you know of course it's a possibility i
mean if if i can
if i with this headset in
creating all these worlds that aren't
there then surely i'm creating this
world around me and it's not there
either i'm i'm i'm the creator of it
whatever the reality is this is just a
headset to that reality
so i think it will really help our
imaginations that way but in terms of
concrete imagining of specific new kinds
of color
or other kinds of experiences i don't
know
short of taking drugs that sort of like
you know open the doors of perceptions
in certain raw ways
and maybe meditation could do that
there may be some technology that will
do that but what we have right now
the way that scientists do it is we go
there
with mathematics we let mathematics
take us so for example can you imagine a
three-dimensional cube sure
can you mention a four-dimensional cube
nothing happens right
einstein had to be thinking in four
dimensions to write down
his you know equations for general
relativity he had to have a
four-dimensional
but he couldn't visualize it so the
mathematics was
allowed einstein to go where visual
imagination
couldn't and now we can go five six ten
dimensions in mathematics
and we can go there even though the
mathematicians will tell you they can't
visualize
anything and yet there's a way that our
imaginations are going there because we
have this cognitive level
this tool that takes our our
ability to only concretely imagine three
dimensions
and leverage that into the abstract
ability
to work in any number of dimensions but
we can't visualize it
and so that's so we can use mathematics
to
explore abstractly what's in girdle's
candy store
but it won't actually let us taste it
wow okay so we will
be able to make
all these novel combinatorics of candies
um the trick is going to be to enable us
to actually taste
right that's right that's right just
like you mean the the simple problem
you can't you know imagine a specific
color you've never seen before
and nothing happens yeah if i discover
all these new structures that
consciousness can have and i say okay
well imagine what it's like well you
concretely
won't be able to do it just like you
can't imagine a specific color
so so what we can do in some sense
what we're getting from the mathematics
is boy are there all these really really
intriguing candies out there that are
beckoning yeah
and uh i'm telling you that they're
there but you can't taste them right now
yeah yeah yeah there's there's all
there's this um
there's this an infinite
um catalog of
of of valence of of conscious experience
that is available of such
wild combinatorics that are way beyond
our own color wheel and tastes
of candies um that right now we're just
talking
about but that nobody has tasted or
experienced and so we want to
we want to just shatter that and and
send lots of conscious agents out to
experience
that right and that's from this point of
view from this framework
in which consciousness is fundamental
that's what consciousness is up to
it shoots all sorts of explorations and
we're and you and i are just some of
those explorations we're exploring this
particular
candy in a particular part of the candy
store and we're using minkowski space
and physical objects to do it
and um and most of us have no idea that
there's anything else right this is the
only candy in the store and
and we're happy but this is just one of
the boundless candies
and um it's fun to wake up to that it
may be frustrating too if we sit here
and going but oh but i can't experience
them
and by the way even the mathematicians
based on girdle is incomplete this term
even the mathematicians can't abstractly
even begin
to explore just the mathematical
structures right but by the way this is
great job security for mathematics this
is provable job security
this is you will never come to the last
theorem
never so this is sign up for being a
mathematician because you know
that you have endless employment
agi will help us uh create those
novel um theorems that help push the
edges
further i wanna i wanna ask you about um
that auroboros so at does does it then
if we are
um creating the the if we if we
are a one that is having
the um dissociative as bernardo castro
talks about experience of of the nerve
endings
that we are having the experience in in
the reality that we ourselves have
designed and made
that then um
that we of course must not get lost in
the own
um in the own infinite labyrinth of our
creation but we must
um go towards that that whatever
attractor of a
of a star that we're all in a sense like
orthogenically
um building towards right now and is
that star
that we're building towards is that a
recursion is that the transcension
hypothesis is that
all of us as conscious agents
going through the process of
making more experience
tasting more of the candies in the store
so is our recursive godhead function
to just taste more candies in the
infinite store that we will
infinitely forever eternally be
exploring
well that is the kind of idea that that
i'm
i'm pursuing here so so absolutely and
and this
but this question really touches on
something that you brought up before
which
is that there are many wisdom traditions
over thousands of years that have said
very very similar things and
and and and in some sense as a scientist
i'm sort of
a johnny come lately right science is
sort of a johnny come lately to this but
but the science is is coming along but
but the kind of answer to the question
that you just raised
will require
that we take all the insights from the
wisdom traditions
and then we also take the rigors of the
scientific method
in terms of theory building and careful
testing
and bring these together in a
synergistic interaction